the eyes to the right
382
the nose to the left
128.
the bill's approval clears the way for a
revolution in reproductive medicine
thank you
it's good news for families like the
holidays a mutation in mother vicky's
mitochondria has left their daughter
jessica with a life-threatening
condition
so as you can see she's very floppy she
can't really hold her own head up she
doesn't have the energy to do that so
effectively her brain is dying and
it's a matter of time before that
affects the brain stem
mitochondria are tiny energy generating
structures found outside the nucleus of
cells when they're faulty incurable
conditions can arise which are passed
down the maternal line
but scientists in britain have found a
way to transfer the nucleus of an egg
with defective mitochondria into an egg
from a healthy donor the resulting
fertilized egg contains the parents
nuclear material along with the healthy
mitochondria from the donor
when someone is anemic you may replace
the red cells because they can't
function properly essentially with
mitochondrial transfer you're replacing
mitochondria from a healthy person in
the same way it's a transfusion
effectively which will then allow them
to use energy wisely but the only
difference of course is
that this is then passed on to the next
generation
those in favor say the technique does
not change the baby's genetic makeup but
this isn't genetic modification we're
not altering the nucleus we're not
altering those fifty percent of genes
that come from each parent it's
0.054 percent
of the genome opponents say it crosses a
fundamental moral line
altering the genes of a child creating a
new child essentially
opening the way to determining the type
of person who is born is a very
difficult ethical boundary to cross
the vote has come too late for jessica
holliday but it will give her parents
the chance to have a second child free
of her condition